okay movie retrospective time I haven't
wanted to do this one forever I love
this [ __ ] movie it's good movie and
yeah so this has been on my list since
the beginning and actually I think
somebody requested it like a few months
ago when I was like man we need to
[ __ ] do this and we saw that you
could run it on YouTube or Xbox or
whatever so so yeah you can run on
YouTube too yeah and so I was very very
excited it's like we got to finally do
this one this is death becomes her yeah
this came out in 1992 I might have seen
this in the theater cuz I feel like me
and my friend were going to the dollar
theatre a bunch back and around 1992 and
this looks like something that we would
have gone to see if I didn't then I must
have seen it like in 93 like on cable or
whatever and I probably saw it like a
million times so when we were watching
it again last night
I was just like I remembered almost
there maybe like all the lines and
everything like we saw remaster so this
is available like an in HD and you know
yeah because this is one movie that it's
held up very famously when it came out
on DVD the DVD transfer was notoriously
shitty I mean and it was just kind of
like it looked like they had taken what
the rumor was going around at the time
that they had just taken the version
from the laserdisc and it just
transferred it to DVD without like
adjusting it to the format or anything
so it was supposedly I haven't seen it
but it was supposed to look really
really crappy like really muddy like the
colors and everything but it has since
been redone I think it came out on
blu-ray in 2016 or 2017 finally the
thing about this it's it's a weird movie
because it was directed by the very
famous Robert Zemeckis do they did Back
to the Future Back to the Future he did
and did everything this was actually the
movie that he did between Back to the
Future 3 and Forrest Gump okay so this
was kind of like fell in the middle now
the weird thing about this is that even
though this got kind of like mixed
critical reviews at the time but was
actually a pretty big commercial success
it actually came out this is hilarious
but it actually came out the same
weekend as the Buffy the Vampire Slayer
movie the one with Kristy Swanson and
Luke Perry and stuff that the later TV
show is based on and this like kicked
its ass just like made all kind of money
if
a dark comedy yeah and but it's done in
that zemeckis tone it feels like Back to
the Future 1 & 2 conduct if it was if
that was like a horror yet like what you
end up with is some kind of like a Tim
Burton movie but not quite as Burton II
yeah Tim Burton II feelings sometimes
can overpower you this kind of has a
Back to the Future kind of upbeat tone
to it even though it has a lot of dark
[ __ ] even though it's pretty not
murder and demented a Living Dead I'm
not like that
it's about this these people all their
50s it's group of basically three
friends two women and a guy they're all
hit fit they're all hit their 50s and
they're all losing their [ __ ] mojo
and one of them some movie stars she's
just not as hot as she was the other one
you know it's like in crustle wife was
building on Goldie Hawn and she's
[ __ ] loses her man who is the [ __ ]
Bruce Willis to the old [ __ ] movie
star well they were it was when that
happen when they were younger though
when they got older it all the [ __ ] all
started to fall apart
and to make a long story short Goldie
Hawn secretly found out a way this cult
it was like a [ __ ] Isis cult or a
[ __ ] I think it was Isis or was it
she's like I get the woman that she gets
the potion down um yeah I guess she's
like a sorceress they don't really go in
issuing an ancient Egyptian cult though
there's all these Egyptian motif going
on and if they have this elixir of life
that can give you eternal life yeah and
it turns out turns out that all the
[ __ ] famous people you thought you
had died they were actually still alive
they just faked their joining a Elvis
James D anyone road they're all there
Greta Garbo and they're all have nothing
parties and [ __ ] you know to be while
you're not looking and in this big
mansion outside LA and anyway it's just
a badass flick [ __ ] there's a catch
to this immortality though you can't die
yes I mean you can but then your body
will start to decay just like if you're
really dead but you still be alive just
alive you'll just be the living dead
yeah so well murder plot starts
happening over [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know the man left the wife
for the other woman they all you know
and she tries to get him to kill her it
just got to see the movie it's it's
[ __ ] hilarious
I mean yeah I'm gonna spoil this like I
said it came out in 1992 I [ __ ] love
this movie it's really funny because I
feel like I feel like the late 80s and
the early to mid 90s if you don't work
if you're gonna see this movie go ahead
and check out now cuz she's gonna spoil
a [ __ ] yeah movie and a movie if
you've never seen it it's an epic film
it's it's about like Back to the Future
movie this movie is hysterical
yes and it still makes me [ __ ] laugh
to this day I think this was the first
time it was either this movie or
she-devil with rips a bar which was the
first time that I saw Meryl Streep doing
comedy and I was amazed at how [ __ ]
hilarious she is she is so [ __ ] good
both her and Goldie Hawn like play off
each other so well in this they are just
so so [ __ ] yeah this and it's
wonderful yeah and really this movie
kind of stands outside of time you know
if you're young you can appreciate the
movie and it does there's a lesson to
learn from the movie it's a morality
tale yeah but it really hits home when
you're in your 50s yeah so you get close
to 50 you're gonna yeah and I laughed
because I was doing something I think it
was a piece in Vanity Fair or something
like that and they were talking about
this movie
and they said that the person that wrote
it said they saw this movie when they
were like 10 years old and they loved it
because it's kind of like it's like a
magical realism or like a supernatural
comedy type of thing but they said once
you get it older like it really like
resonates on a whole new level because
you can relate to the characters I'm
like wanting to hold on to their youth
and stuff like that yeah but I was gonna
say that I feel like the period from
like maybe from like 88 or 89 like when
Beetlejuice came out maybe to like the
mid 90s I feel like that was kind of the
heyday of these sort of supernatural
horror comedies or magical realism type
things like I said you had beetlejuice
you had the frighteners yeah you had
practical man
JQ @ hocus pocus in the witches of
eastwick yeah like what and I love like
all those [ __ ] movies so I feel like
that was kind of like the the heyday of
that type of movie which maybe
Beetlejuice kicked that off um I feel
cuz I feel like that was kind of the
first big movie that was like that and
they were kind of morality tales all of
them in a certain yeah yes yes this one
I think more so this one is when you get
to the end you you it's definitely a
morality tale oh yeah big time
definitely you know there's different
kinds of immortality that's what the
[ __ ] moral moral of the story is yeah
and it's also kind of a skewering of
trying to stay young at any cost and uh
you know kind of like the whole
Hollywood thing of eternal youth but
particularly like you know is regard to
like starlets and stuff like that like
this superficial beauty once yeah once
they get into their 40s and stuff like
that they kind of you know or get thrown
away because they're not beautiful and
young anymore and stuff like that so it
kind of has that kind of like vibe to it
too but yeah so the interesting thing
about this so like I said Meryl Streep
is in this playing she plays Madeleine
and she is kind of like I guess she was
kind of like a famous movie star like
back in the day because they do show
like later on there's like a clip of her
in a movie with Michael Caine which I
the scene with her that's you know not
real obviously she wasn't in that movie
but the Michael Caine's and I'm pretty
sure that was from the Ipcress file that
was from 1965 so they just like put her
into that movie so but she's kind of
like even when the movie starts it's in
1978 and even by then she's a little bit
of a has-been because she's kind of like
doing this horrible Broadway
off-broadway musical based on sweet
sweet bird of youth which is a Tennessee
Williams play I think and it's just like
this really depressing the thing about
like a gigolo or something so it's like
the the the fact that they made a
musical out of it is like a joke also
but you'd have to kind of know about you
know about that plan about what it was
about like for that to be funny but um
but you can tell though that it's a
really horrible you know musical because
it's like she's just singing all about
herself and how awesome she is like I
said she's kind of like a has-been at
this point and then they try to like
inject some disco and - and there's all
these gay Bell Ups and it's like it's
just hysterical so and you know
everyone's get
up and leaving so apparently there is
they don't go a huge amount into you
know where Madeline and goldie Hawn's
character met what goldie Hawn's
characters named Helen and she's like a
writer so apparently they were friends
when they were younger because there is
a kind of a conversation later on where
you know Madeline kept stealing Helens
boyfriends just to be a [ __ ] and you
know I guess Helen thought that Madeline
was like low-class or trash or something
like that because I guess Helen comes
from like it more of an upper-class
family so there's like this rivalry
there essentially frenemies is what they
are you know they pretend to be like
friends but then they're always like
these throwing shade on each other is
only like you know pointed Barb's and
everything and they're always trying to
like undermine one another all the time
and trying to like this sounds familiar
doesn't it J yeah and so it's like this
this horrible like competition between
them all the time because they all it's
like like I said and a lot of people do
have like friendships like this where
they kind of keeps a person around but
then they're constantly like trying to
like cut them down all the time and
they're always trying to be better than
them and that's kind of what you see
with these two characters a lot of women
are liked it yeah well yeah some of them
are so you know what I mean so so that's
kind of like the heart of the movie now
at the beginning of the film which is in
1978 so goldie Hawn's character helen
has taken her fiancee played by bruce
willis who was a very like fav like
celebrity plastic surgeon so he's kind
of like a big deal to and she takes him
to the to see Madeline's play or her
musical and she's like I wanted you know
I wanted you to like pass this test I
have to introduce like all my boyfriends
or so like that to her to make sure that
she doesn't steal them because that's
what she does she steals all healthiest
boyfriends and now what they did with
this is they it's really great because
they made Goldie Hawn at the beginning
like look really really frumpy which she
is not because she is a beautiful woman
and you know was particularly beautiful
at this time and so it's very funny how
they just made her look like not ugly
but just like kind of plain now so Bruce
Willis who this was kind of like not
that long after die hard came out so he
was like big action star and I thought
it was kind of cool that they got him to
sort of play against type at the time he
plays this
nebbishy schlubby frumpy frumpy like
balding like he's okay at the beginning
but then as it goes on he turns to like
this boozy like alcoholic by the time
he's 50 he's washed up yeah and now he
wasn't the original choice for this role
I heard it was actually supposed to be
Kevin Kline which might have worked too
although I'm not sure because Kevin
Kline comes across as like funnier like
more like I don't want to say he's more
charming than Bruce Willis but I feel
like that comedic like charm and stuff
like that might have made him seem less
schlubby in this role but Bruce Bruce
Willis really [ __ ] brings it I mean
he goes all in with like the sad sack
dirtiness with this and it really really
worked this is one of Willis's best
movies it really is like he's really
really good at this right and n it it's
not it there is action in it but it's
not die hard style action it's just you
know he [ __ ] kills a couple of his
wives or almost like it's almost like a
live-action Looney Tunes cartoon like
not quite as zany as that but I mean cuz
the whole thing so there's the rivalry
between like so so Madeleine like um
steals Helens fiancee and marries him
and then it kind of like this goes ahead
at a pretty good clip like it skips
ahead seven years it skips ahead seven
years now what ends up happening is that
Helen goliad's character she is so
[ __ ] up by helot by Madeline again
stealing her man that she has turned
into this like a big fat cat cat lady
who the hoarder and a hoarder who lives
in this horrible apartment who eats like
cake frosting like right in the keys all
day there's an answer in the coverage
and [ __ ] like that and she is just
obsessed and she's like watching this
scene from this movie where Madeline
gets killed like as an actress and she
just watches it over and over again
later she's in a damn mental home yeah
so they put her to mental hope I guess
because she she hadn't paid her rent and
she got arrested cuz it's like she
wouldn't vacate the premises or whatever
so she gets arrested and they put her in
a mental home and she's in there for
like I don't know how long it's just
seven years or just driving all them
crazy and it's driving all the because
that's all she wants to talk about is
that woman and how she stole my man and
it's like she's obsessed with it and
then finally she has a breakthrough and
she realizes she finally he has to get
past it
or she won't be able to have a life and
then another seven years go by Madeline
and and Ernest who is Bruce Willis's
character they've been married they
despise each other they live in this
[ __ ] massive mansion and everything
but you know he's like I guess he's
become such an alcoholic that he can't
do plastic surgery anymore so he can't
get it up either yes so in which yes she
goes into that but yeah so he's now like
an undertaker like he uses his expertise
now to like make bodies look like yeah
you know all of a sudden and she's fed
with us fabulously [ __ ] rich you're
talking about [ __ ] you know huge
mansion yeah so they both so I'm not
real clear on like whose money it is
it's I guess it's both of their money
because they were both like like a good
head but she was a big movie star and he
was like a really famous plastic surgeon
so I'm imagining that so I don't think
it was one person's money or the other
person's money but yeah so they um so so
[ __ ] madeline is like you know she's
older at this stage and she's the the
cool thing about Meryl Streep in this
role is another thing too is she was not
afraid to like make herself look like
complete hammered [ __ ] in this movie
there is a great [ __ ] scene where her
maid comes in to wake her up and she's
sitting she's laying in her bed like up
she's got like the neck pillow she's got
like all the tape like on her face and
like [ __ ] like tied like that like to
keep her face from sagging and she's
like she's got me to tell her this she
looks younger and younger every day
she's got this young boyfriend who's the
caretaker Dakota yeah [ __ ] she walks
up on in the [ __ ] you know he lives he
lives on you know on premise in the
guest house yeah yeah in the in the
[ __ ] worker man's house or whatever
and she looks in and he's [ __ ] nailing
this you know hot young baby cries the
[ __ ] blow it off and then he runs out
is ago you know what do you expect they
say I look ridiculous with you and she
say he starts like the slamming on her
yeah it's [ __ ] hilarious because you
know it's like this is engaged it was
great thing about this though is that as
horrible as her character is and as
horrible as goldie Hawn's character is i
mean these are horrible horrible people
they are shallow they're vain
they're vindictive and petty and venal
and they're just these terrible people
but you still kind of feel sorry for
them a little bit
which i think is what makes it work so
so they've gotten invited so that was
like you know one straw that broke the
camel's back but also they get invited
to Helens you know book party she has a
book that's come out and it's like
hugely hugely successful and so they go
to the party and you know Madeline is
still thinking that Helen still looks
like a big fatso and so she goes to the
party but she sees that now goldie hawn
looks amazing and she's like you know
release all these big dress she looks
like Veronica Lake and she's got like
all the hair and she looks like really
really young and so uh energetic a
rabbit dress yeah and so Madeleine is
like really really upset and she's like
what the [ __ ] do I do so she she had
tried to like go to this spa you know to
get like transfusion with children and
[ __ ]
yeah they're like a great [ __ ]
speaking I thought one review that said
it was like a Terry Gilliam movie which
it was kind of where it's like a dude
getting his black [ __ ] blood replaced
or some [ __ ] like that
so they goes there's like look where
there's nothing we can do to help you in
like one day cuz she wanted all her
blood per place too but they're like
look we just replaced all your blood
like three weeks ago we can't do that
[ __ ] but then this one guy that works
there gives her this card it's like
here's this woman that may be able to
help you so at first like she doesn't
want to do it cuz she's like that just
sounds like [ __ ] but after all this
[ __ ] happens with Dakota and seeing
Goldie Hawn like looking like fantastic
she's like she gets desperate so she
feels like maybe she should do something
about it so she ends up going to this
like ridiculous mansion and meets Liesel
who is played by Isabella Rossellini
looking fabulous oh my god Egyptian
goddess and [ __ ] Wow yeah when I saw
this [ __ ] movie the first time it's
like that outfit that she wears the
first time you see her with like that
it's not even a top it's like a necklace
but it just kind of covers her boobs or
it's like sarong it she's got the knife
later they're just like she looks
amazing he's got a whole harem of these
damn muscle building bodybuilder Fabio
the model dude has a metal spandex pants
and [ __ ] tails for the top you know I
mean and they all get the [ __ ] a little
security [ __ ] security microphones in
there [ __ ] the ears and [ __ ] you know
at her beck and call and they're like
her sex slaves to their yeah
these big [ __ ] muscle men protecting
their I love it yeah she's in this
[ __ ] just [ __ ] gigantic [ __ ]
William Randolph Hearst style [ __ ]
stone mansion outside yeah they're just
looking living in opulence and she gives
her a [ __ ] line she tells her that
she can [ __ ] bring make her eternally
young and you know brings out this damn
[ __ ] box the Egyptian [ __ ] shard
of Cristal the with blue big Faberge egg
cuz she [ __ ] the glowing [ __ ]
ointment in the bottom of the damn
[ __ ] bottle is pointed but no matter
where it stands up like magnetic and I
was like a cherub and basically you know
she didn't say how much she wanted she
just wrote down the price she said it's
different for everybody even for
everybody but she showed her the how
much it cost
yeah on a piece of Meryl Streep was like
I don't know nothing and then you know
she burned the paper so you never did
see how much it cost but she gave her a
little drop of it in a cut on her finger
and [ __ ] when that hand got young she
was like okay how much yeah check okay
to the yeah she gave it to her and she
got young [ __ ] instantly generators
are like a good [ __ ] yeah her face
gets all gorgeous looking yeah so she
goes home [ __ ] tries to work her
magic and [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so the
great thing about this movie like you
don't find out later on that Goldie Hawn
had also taken the potion but many years
prior yeah it's just why she looks so
fantastic but one thing that all that
Liesl says like before madeleine leaves
is take care of your body it will be you
and it will be together for a very long
time yeah she doesn't really specify
that if you die in that body like or if
you get hurt in that body trapped in it
you're still trapped in it like you will
live forever but that doesn't
necessarily mean that the body is gonna
like if you [ __ ] it up yeah it's gonna
stay [ __ ] up yeah and if you die
you're still in it and I guess it's kid
starts to slowly decay anyway yeah it
doesn't seem to heal if you're dead I I
guess if you're alive it will heal yeah
but if you're dead yeah because the the
[ __ ] did that so I think but but the
fact that they died because like
all the people that were at the party
like at the end were people that had
taken this F so they were immortal and
they still all looked young and
everything the only reason they started
you know deteriorating was because they
both died because that's what happens is
that it turns out that she has not I
mean it hasn't even been like an hour
two before she took the [ __ ] so she goes
back to the house she puts on like her
[ __ ] you know she looks all fabulous
she puts on like her black cat suit and
like her little did think she's gonna go
out and like go out on the town and get
some dick and basically she's her then
her Bruce Willis getting like this big
fight and she just keeps like [ __ ]
needling him and Anita Lee came she's a
boozy place of flying [ __ ] they get it
to a fight he [ __ ] those guys
downstairs and it kills well yeah well
he starts like choking her and it's like
she starts stumbling down the stairs and
then he's like oh [ __ ] what am i doing
and then she's like help me and they
just like she's like help me you idiot
or something like that and then he goes
big and she falls all the way down and
she's like all [ __ ] up and yeah her
legs are all backwards and [ __ ] so
obviously he thinks she's dead now him
and Helen have actually been conspiring
to kill her anyway and make it look like
an accident which honestly I think
that's probably of you know of all the
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] that's in this
movie this might be one of my favorite
sequences is when Goldie Hawn is telling
him she's like look I've thought this
all through and this is the only way we
can do it and she's like telling him the
plan and they're kind of like showing it
they were going to drugged her and then
put her in a car and then you know run
the car off a cliff and there's like
just there's so much funny [ __ ] in this
with her she's like we'll just say that
they're you know that she's had a little
too much to drink and they should
there's like 40 [ __ ] vodka bottles
like in the car and [ __ ] like that and
then at the end like after they find the
body like there's two coroner's and it's
like the body's all [ __ ] burned like
with a vodka bottle and it's like well
she had it coming
it's like that kind of [ __ ] it's just a
great [ __ ] scene but then obviously
even though she is all like Madeline's
all [ __ ] up at the bottom of the show
so she gets up and she's not real happy
about a head on back up straight ahead
right now eventually what happens is
that she blasts the other girl
[ __ ] butt belly with a shotgun yeah
no no and then she comes back to life
cuz she didn't know that she's taking
the post she's like YouTube so now you
got two living dead girls [ __ ]
chasing [ __ ] dude around [ __ ]
Bruce Willis is dealing with these two
Living Dead chicks who hate each other
and hate each other and who fight with
shovels and are trying to like killing
they need him to [ __ ] keep them
looking decent because one of them's got
a big ol hole where he got she got blown
in half with a shotgun and the other
ones got her [ __ ] head is so I can
bust it up
next day he's putting bondo on I'm and
[ __ ] like that makeup yeah because there
was a scene earlier like before anybody
dies where he's at this bar and like
this woman comes up to him and is like
oh you know you're that year doctor
Melville it's like I never got to tell
you how awesome you did a job like write
an or whoever it was like at the funeral
she looked like you even brought over
the cheekbones it was a shame to bury
her and all this other kind of stuff and
she asks him like what her what his
secret is and it's funny to me because
she asked even though she clearly didn't
want to know because when he starts
telling her she's just like okay I'm out
here cuz he's like you know my secret is
he's like spray paint damn he's like
because well he's like you well you
can't use makeup on dead people because
the skin is too dry so you have to let
go get this [ __ ] so he goes it was
long vague about screaming it's got its
own adhesive and you have to leave let
me get so upset so the fact that he
knows how to do that like how to make
dead bodies look good so the two women
who are now dead and her kind of like
falling apart and decaying they want to
keep him around to keep them looking
good like forever so they try to get him
to drink the potion as well but he
doesn't want to do that for various
reasons it's a bunch of cool [ __ ] in the
movie too you know little stuff that if
you weren't paying attention you may not
you may not notice it like there's one
part where Bruce Willis falls from the
top of the damn building
[ __ ] his two girlfriends were trying
to save you but they could his two dead
girlfriends at renovation they couldn't
get him in time and he fell through a
damn stained glass roof into the
swimming pool and he so he survived the
fall he came out there's a dude and dude
take it
closed-off and as a girl taking his
clothes off getting ready to go swim
when he goes you go you're gonna be done
here in a minute
or should we come back he says no no I'm
done here
and [ __ ] and he runs out dude goes
that was pretty neat and if you paid
attention if you paid attention to who
it was you know it was [ __ ] Jim Moore
just all kinds of fun oh my god there's
just so much funny [ __ ] and like I said
this the line delivery and this
particularly Meryl Streep's delivery
line
she is just the [ __ ] she says it's just
so funny like the [ __ ] arguments they
get into like you know her and Bruce
Willis that whole argument they have on
the stairs before he starts strangling
her the [ __ ] with like her and Goldie
Hawn like their [ __ ] you know
constant sniping at each other and [ __ ]
like that it's like when before you know
before Madeleine takes the potion and
she goes to like the book party and sees
like Goldie Hawn like looking fabulous
she goes up and you know goldie Hawn's
like they're they pretend like they
lived oh how are you and they call each
other mad in hell which i think is very
funny that's right and yes that's the
short forms of their names and she says
something like she says thing like you
know I wasn't gonna invite you and stuff
I didn't know if you'd want to come
because you know she was trying to make
it seem like oh I didn't think you'd
care about my book or whatever she's
like I didn't think you want to come but
then I talked to my PR person and my PR
person said Madeleine will go to the
opening of an envelope it's just so so
[ __ ] she's like so I fired her well I
almost fired her you know I mean so it's
like just this really [ __ ] and I think
this whole kind of over-the-top [ __ ]
can't be kind of aesthetic to it this is
why I actually didn't really know much
about this but this has kind of become a
cult classic even though you know it was
a commercial success at the time but
then it kind of got forgotten about
particularly like in the gay community
and honestly like I heard that RuPaul's
Drag Race which I think it was season 7
which I haven't seen but I think they
did like a death becomes her like
inspired like runway or show or
something like that so apparently this
is a really big things like drag
performers like I could see what you
know
for them to like dress up as these
characters just because they're
bitchiness is just delicious and just
the way and also the cool thing about
this movie too and I think like I said
this was something that you know campus
like in the frighteners and other types
of movies of this you know time period
where it's almost kind of like it's said
in the real world but not exactly
because there's like little things in it
that aren't really explained but are
kind of like give it this weird like
magical sort of kind of like a burton
flick tone yeah it's like there's stuff
like when like when madeline goes to the
spa and like that dude like appears like
just behind the you know behind them on
the couch like and he didn't come in
it's like when Bruce Willis's character
goes down to the morgue to get to get
Madelyn out and these three nuns go by
and they're like floating yeah like good
goes and like they don't explain
anything like that it's just these
little touches that like kind of make it
seem like it's not exactly happening in
the real world except it kind of is so
like I said it's like a magical realism
type thing there was this one scene one
part of scene where [ __ ] Bruce Willis
his characters trying to get the [ __ ]
out of that damn party I think it was
after he fell through the through the
roof yeah he tried to get out of there
and it just shows the front the front
door of the mansion and people arriving
and there's a silver sports car there it
wasn't a Porsche Spyder but it was it
was like a custom silver little sports
car and he jumps in it take off and a
dude goes hey wait a minute wait a
minute and it was James Dean you know
the relationship between James Dean and
silver spiders yeah that that's what he
got killed him because what that one
thing that um Liesl you know the the
sorceress or whatever one thing that she
says to Madeleine like after she drinks
the potion is that you know go out and
be fantastic and famous and everything
like that for ten years but after that
you have to disappear disappear
you can like fake your death or you can
just like yeah you can become a recluse
or something like that so they're
implying that all of these like famous
people that you know are supposedly dead
are actually still alive yeah they just
had to fake their death after yeah and
she's addressing the whole crowd of them
down you know because the big party and
she's like you know it's good that none
of you guys you know are everybody's
keeps laying low except for one person
who makes appearances that now and then
I'm not gonna name any and it passed
elvis he's got these two women with a
because i was having fun so it's just
like there's just so many great and like
i said it's just every time this movie
cuz like i said i saw this movie like a
million times and i was growing out
because I just [ __ ] love this movie
there's just something the look of it is
so cool it's like I just love like all
the little magical touches that the
comedy is funny like a lot of it it's
weird because a lot of it is like really
like I said like can it be and like
over-the-top and it's like super [ __ ]
and stuff like that yeah but it's also
like there's a lot of really subtle
jokes to like and there's a lot of you
know there's a scene in a doctor's
office where there's like a brain and a
jar that says a be normal on it it's
like when Goldie Hawn and you know Meryl
Streep are fighting about the potion
Goldie Hawn says the date that she took
it which was October whatever 1985 which
was the same day as Marty went back to
the future and back to nature
so he's like making all these references
that you can like it's in universe and
stuff yeah so there's all that kind of
stuff going on and it's just just these
great little lines like I love one
[ __ ] so if when Madeline would you
know she fell down the stairs she broke
her neck she burger but she's all like
[ __ ] up and everything but Bruce
Willis thinks it's a miracle that she's
still alive so it takes her to the
hospital and so the doctors like
examining her and he's like can't get it
he's like you know she's like eighty
degrees it's like she doesn't heartbeat
and it's like her neck is broken the
bone sticking out [ __ ] and so he's like
flipping out so I guess she passes out
and they take her to the morgue
like after Bruce Willis has gone like
his he's gone to find help or whatever
and then you know so he comes back in
the room and she's gone and he's like
where's my wife oh my god and it's like
they're like well they took her to the
morgue she's dead he's but more she'll
be furious he gets her out of a plastic
bag though she comes back back out he
will the weird thing about this movie
because I hadn't seen the trailer like
in a really long time but when we burn
it on Xbox they showed like the the
trailer from the time now there are a
bunch of scenes in the trailer that were
not in the movie like there was a scene
where he was where Bruce
was like taking her out of the
refrigerator and then was like dragging
her up the steps and she's like oh I'm
why am i sweating or something he's like
I think you're defrosting or something
like that now that was not in the movie
I think that was cut out there was also
a whole alternate ending to this I think
there was a whole thing where Bruce
Willis like after he took off because he
didn't want to like hang around and be
like the these two [ __ ] like makeup
artists like forever so he like took off
and he meets Tracey Ullman her part was
completely cut out of this movie
remember yeah she was she was the one
that got the Simpsons there sir yes it
was her TV show that the Simpsons
started on so um so she was in this
movie she played like a bartender or
something like that and he meets her and
then he becomes a bartender and she
helps him like fake his death and all
this other stuff so there was that whole
thing that that was excised I think that
was also I think what ended up happening
was that rock they shot that ending and
Robert Zemeckis was like that ending is
too happy I don't really like it because
the ending of this is great I love the
ending of this movie like with the
funeral like because Bruce Willis lives
like another 37 years or something like
that he got married he got married he
had his first real marriage and just his
life began after fifth after 15 it's
like nobody knows much of anything about
him more you know these kids and
grandkids and he started all these
foundations yeah and then all these
adopted children from across the world
and people uni became citizen and then
the preacher was like there was true
immortality yeah children and
grandchildren and all the foundations
and all the pendants and everything and
it's like meanwhile like the two like
Madden hell who are like they've kind of
gone to [ __ ] because they don't have
anybody around to take care of them
because after he took off they can't
walk on there they were like well [ __ ]
now what do we do and she's like well
it's just maintenance it's like we have
to like help each other out it's like
I'll paint your ass you paper yeah it's
like Oh forever painting each other's
asses and all this other kind of stuff
with the spray paint so 37 years later
they're at his funeral and they have the
veils on and they're just like thinking
it's all [ __ ] they're like whatever
blah yeah there's like cackling back
there like horrible [ __ ] and then
they leave and they're like sniping and
they take their [ __ ] veils off and
they look like completely right all the
paints
Oh cuz they don't really know how to do
it and it's like oh yeah you're all
runny yeah and all those others and
they're sniping about where's that can
of spray-paint you lost upon you did
other stuff and then like at the end
they fall in the can of spray paint we
just fall out of the purse and they fall
and they sure yeah where'd you park the
car yeah it's like like that's no big
thing it's like even though all I can
imagine is like everybody coming out of
Bruce Willis's funeral I mean like I
think oh yeah easily like talking heads
and [ __ ] like that it's just [ __ ]
hilarious
but yeah so great movie it really is I
would put it up there with the Back to
the Future trilogy I'd put it up there
with beetlejuice I put it up there with
what else yeah but it's similar it's it
seemed like or similar to the
frighteners it's kind of gives me that
kind of tone a little bit oh yeah cuz
it's like funny but it's got it's kind
of like a morbid humor which I really
like yeah um I feel like like I said
even though it was commercially
successful
I feel like dark comedies are kind of
like a hard sell you know what I mean
it's it a lot of people seem to not like
them or anything but movie like this can
be revived on streaming though it could
I heard this they were doing a remake of
this or maybe a musical based on this
I'm not real sure no I'm just saying the
original just remaster the original
people can about it show it cuz it's
still applicable today it's it's I was
watching I saw this mu I had never seen
this channel before but I was looking
for other reviews of this and a lot of
people have reviewed this cuz apparently
this is like a really really popular
movie I found this one channel called
movie [ __ ] that was like that they
looked pretty young I don't know how
young it was that it was a woman and
then it was like a really really really
really over-the-top gay guy who was like
adorable and hysterical and they were
drinking wine like through the whole
thing and they had the running tally of
how many wines they were having like it
was like between them and infinite of
being like 30 years lazy because it was
like a 45 minute but and they [ __ ]
loved this movie and they were just like
they knew the whole thing like backwards
and forwards and they're just like
quoting it just like cackling and it was
[ __ ] hilarious
so go watch that because I think they
only have like you know maybe a thousand
or 1500 subscribers yeah and I just
thought it was really really funny what
I liked about it is that it does kind of
the story seems to tilt a little female
but not really you know I mean as a guy
I liked it - yes it was a cool [ __ ] it
it that happened well you could kind of
see it from the dudes point of view yeah
because it was
I mean his arc yeah then all the sudden
you're trapped with these [ __ ] living
dead chicks there right looking yeah
yeah I mean his arc was finding his I
mean he's wrapping his balls because
right the thing is that his life his
whole life had been manipulated right
but because neither now you could argue
that in the beginning like goldie Hawn's
character helen did actually love him
and she was actually upset that he had
been like that he had her psycho though
but yeah but she I mean she kind of
became a psycho through circumstance I
think whereas I think Meryl Streep's
character was just kind of like a [ __ ]
on wheels like from the beginning
because I mean she was like just
stealing men from Goldie Hawn just
because she could just because she
wanted to be an athlete yeah yeah
because she was in competition with her
because she was jealous or whatever so I
so I feel like you know Goldie Hawn was
a little more sympathetic but she like
went completely crazy too obviously they
were both like [ __ ] crazy making a
lot of errors but the thing about Bruce
Willis's character was that you know
once the once the you know the stuff and
the story started happening he was not
you know neither one of them gave a [ __ ]
about him they just wanted you know
Goldie Hawn just wanted him to kill
Madeline and Madeline just wanted him to
stay around to keep her looking good
like and fixing her like when she was
dead so it's like they both just were
using him like as a toy pretty much so
you know him finally like dropping his
nuts and saying I'm gonna be my own
person you know this so he kind of had a
character arc as well like try this
getting away from these Bruce's wipers
Bruce's best movies die hard one it's
just yeah okay but but I would say this
is his best work in terms of acting I
think he did a [ __ ] great job because
he has a lot of leaves a lot of [ __ ] to
do in this when he and he's a very good
I mean I think people forget because now
he's kind of like better known as an
action star but he started out as a
comic actor like he started on
moonlighting so this is kind of like
more along those lines but
like I said he's very good at playing
kind of this schlubby alcoholic loser
who's just been like all the life has
been sucked out of him by this woman so
he it's just like really good seeing him
playing against type like that I'm
particularly like what people are more
familiar with nowadays so he's like
really really good in this and like a
lot of his comic delivery was very funny
like the three of them I wish I kind of
wish they had done more movies together
just because they're so so funny like
the three of them they're just so funny
together um I will say too I just wanted
to mention that this movie the special
effects for 1992 this still looks pretty
[ __ ] good yeah pretty early like
digital effects this was done by
Industrial Light and Magic
they got actually an Oscar for this and
the was the scene where her head like
gets kind of like squished down like
where Goldie Hawn hits Meryl Streep with
the shovel and then she has to pull her
head back up where that where you can
see like the neck and everything like
that that's the first time that they had
ever done like CG to do skin tones or
you know skin texture and they actually
used that the following year in Jurassic
Park so this was like the first time
that they had used that effect and they
used it much later yeah that's good it
was good enough yeah it's like you can
still say it's not perfect because it
was 1992 but for 1992 I mean it still
looks pretty in it matches the tone of
the movie - yeah movie has a slightly
fantasy kind of a fantasy like
cartoonish kind of tone to it yes I
wasn't really matters yes so it doesn't
really matter that it doesn't look
exactly like realistic because it just
matches cuz like I said this it's
clearly not the real world I mean
everything you know the first part that
said in New York and the second part of
this said in Hollywood but it's clear
like a fantastical you know setting it's
a fantastical la it's a fantastical New
York it doesn't look like the real thing
exactly very good movie about life it is
yeah was kind of a lot to say like I
said about about immortality and if you
really want that or anything and also
like I said about aging and baby and
stuff like that aging vanity
relationships yeah it's well yeah and
just seriously watch this [ __ ] movie
it's just like but honestly everything
is awesome about this move
but still like just the bitching between
Goldie Hawn and Meryl Streep is just
[ __ ] priceless and this and I could
just watch it all day long because it's
funny as [ __ ] but yeah so seriously it's
you bred it on YouTube I think it's like
$2.99 or three done and then rent on an
Xbox I'm sure it streaming other places
too but it's a [ __ ] great movie and I
feel like a lot of people don't talk
about it kind of god yes so definitely
[ __ ] say it